We really have customers who, atypical
for Germans, at least
historically, spend a lot of
their income on high-quality
food and simply
value it and I think that
actually makes the difference, so
I don't think we're a chic
Micki baker  It's often been
said to us that we only
appeal to high-priced or price-insensitive customers. I don't think that's the
case and we see that too, so we
really have from to all people from
students who traditionally at least do
n't have that much money or
at least  As a student, I didn't have that
much money, but it was really worth it
that it was organic and
Bioland and, above all, that it
tasted good and was good